hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Spooky's House of
jump-scares now I have played this game
before but there have been a lot of
updates since I last played it this was
actually released on Steam and they
added a whole bunch more levels so what
I'm gonna do because I don't know how
much new content there is I'm gonna
start at 500 oh I don't know the
password like I mean I can look it up
okay I found the password the password
is cheese and I remember that because
the last time a hello hi yep good to be
back like the Energizer Bunny I bet I'm
in the jokin before Thank You spooky I'm
just gonna keep going on cuz I am such a
boss now I actually do like this game a
lot because it is a lot of fun but I'm
gonna need to do a little bit of
exploring before I get back to where I
was for you guys because oh that's
familiar oh wait this is bad just go too
bad okay it's okay
dammit I keep forgetting something about
this game like it seems so innocent if
you haven't seen me play it before it
seems really innocent but this game is
absolutely horrifying once you get
deeper and darker into it oh maybe I
should look around error cannot release
twice exit through Express
oh hey Express okay this is gonna be the
shortcut to get me back to where I was
in level 500 I believe that the last
time I played this I got up to about 600
or something but there wasn't enough
content enabled in the game such that I
could keep going so I'm just gonna come
back when I get to new stuff hello
this is new hello right now I'm not
surprised hello I'm looking into the
same I'm gonna come back when I find
more new stuff because this game was
released on Steam since the last time
that I played it so we're gonna get to
play a lot of things it's been a while
since I played that the last time I
played bye
oh you sassy bastard you you little
green cute jelly was that I heard a
thing
you can't tell me I didn't because I did
I know my ears ain't broke why am I so
jumpy I don't know goddammit that's why
okay that's why I don't know what they
are but those definitely are not deer I
could have told you that from before do
you really yeah I can get the ax now
okay click to swing great those acts
bastards
Oh what am I in the matrix what the hell
okay I'm in trouble now because now I
got the deer caught after me well I
thought it was gonna be the Majora's
Mask part but apparently not
Bernsen yes apparently not well that's
awfully Pleasant music for me dying and
all that stuff but could you go away
[ __ ] it's probably right behind
probably don't even need to look here I
go I'm looking dear God oh god it takes
stamina to swing I'm okay I'm okay you
dear God they could give me what I need
to stop doing that
because I'm an idiot
son of a [ __ ] don't do that to me stop
that it would have been done
oh hi how's it going at first this place
just seemed cute but I've been here for
days now okay being watched by that the
thing about this game that really gets
you after a while is it it lulls you
into a false sense of security
so you think that you're gonna be okay
in all honesty they're about to stab
many knives up into your buttocks
oh yeah it's resonating whilst I forgot
about that god it's been a while there's
been a long time Oh God I got dear God
on my assho please don't please dude did
I need to smash why is this this why is
this different things are different now
I don't much appreciate that that better
have been a pole dancing pole and not
nothing else I don't like the fact that
things are different cuz I don't know
different
clearly I don't know the same oh crap
what is this baloney
what is this malarkey what is this what
is this this what does this look like
quaint graphics okay did I do good
oh I did good didn't I
this old place is somehow even worse
than the new GL labs although it seems
to have been constructed with a much
larger budget than the new lab nothing
works quite right I can see why it was
abandoned so quickly I wonder if there
really is anything here were selling
probably not probably all bunch of death
son I'd imagine
hello this is suddenly new great oh I
don't like to this turn in the dead
space okay dear God's gonna get me so
besides being cowards I wonder what I'm
supposed hello
this facility is quite odd some of the
equipment doesn't seem to quite right
almost as if it were designed for people
without hands also I'm not sure if it's
just faulty electronics but the power
keeps fluctuating and weird noises are
coming from the air ducts great
are they Nick remorse are they horrible
party monsters are they something even
worse than there are there's something
more clever than what I can come up with
on the fly Oh got an axe it's not
technologically advanced but it'll still
kill you dead whatever is gonna pop it I
regret everything I just said do I have
to go in there oh don't mind me just
crawling around the frickin air ducts
like an idiot thank you good thing I got
my trusty ax
it'll sure help me when I'm about to die
from something spooky just said that
there were things we needed to salvage
from this place I'm starting to worry
that a loose specimen may be included in
the list of things for us to retrieve
the Pirates shut off again is everything
broken in here
um yes probably because some idiot was
swinging an axe around the air ducts
hmm generator what is that
well that's fun okay
Oh goddamn it what the [ __ ] I don't know
what just happened but I think I almost
died or I peed my pants maybe even both
I don't like that sound what's that ring
happening around my vision it says it's
dirt on my screen or am I actually gonna
be in trouble now oh I'm gonna be in
trouble now
I'm gonna be in so much trouble now Oh
God stop doing that to me hey I will
murder you excuse the cracking in my
voice okay I can't see a damn thing
stop that seizure warning oh god why oh
why oh why oh why I did it - oh it
flipped me around damn it
oh come on come on come on keep going
keep going I gotta make it in time
before I lose my mind let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go go go go go oh okay I just got
to make it to the next door before it
gets me so I'm gonna lose my mind
and I'm gonna die keep it going keep
going keep it up keep it up keep it up
stop that stop that don't do that don't
do that don't do that don't do that okay
here we go
cool boy you stupid Skellington god
you're such a dick you're such a pretty
dick shut up Jesus stop that hello
I'm not supposed to play you I don't
have the time
can I have that ink okay yeah I know I
know oh I know what that is uh I think I
know what that is I remember that that
was the thing that I encountered before
I don't know what it is though
okay 66 yay
nothing happened great I went right by
that high cuz it go away oh that's bad
is it something behind me I gotta I
gotta be careful not to get trapped
because I'm going to lose where the door
is that I'm gonna be so screwed
woah woah woah woah woah woah woah hey
wait a minute why were the doors gone
why was the door wall goddamn and
bada-bing balloons
700 yay how did this do for me how did
this do for me it didn't do a damn thing
okay so I'm done with 600 through 700 so
I will pick up 700 through whatever else
is in store for me in another episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I really do love this game it's so
pleasantly artistically made and yet so
horrifically rendering okay so that is
600 to 700 I will pick up 700 plus
levels later for whatever new stuff they
have in store for me in another episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you haven't seen already check out
the other episodes that I did of rooms
one through 500 they are equally scary
and a lot of fun thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video